in 1904 st. Louis hosted an Olympic
marathon for the ages overshadowed by
the neighboring World's Fair the poorly
planned event was reduced to a
lackluster sideshow primed for disaster
during a sweltering 90 degree day the
runners were thrust onto a hellish route
that cut through car traffic rocks thick
dust and 300-foot hills of the 32
athletes who competed only 14 finished
and of the 14 these are the three worth
knowing about
this repeat story was made possible by a
six sound mind sound body Fred lorz was
a fresh-faced athlete ready to make a
name for himself for nine miles lures
was near the front of the pack
until painful muscle cramps stopped him
in his tracks and he wasn't the only one
almost every single racer had severe
muscle cramps that day thanks to this
dummy chief event organizer and amateur
scientist James Sullivan UC Sullivan
turned the event into an experiment to
grasp how purposeful dehydration affects
athletes immune to common sense
Sullivan put a single water station at
the 11th mile mark so for 26 miles
the runners relied on one water station
that was dirty and gave you dysentery
James Sullivan what a guy
boobs anyway back to lures with the Sun
beating down road dusk clogging his
lungs and his muscles spazzing in
protest
Laura's had enough and traded in his two
legs for four wheels he hitched a car
ride to the 19th mile mark got out and
gingerly ran through the finish line the
crowd went wild but before the gold
medal could be placed around his neck
his ruse was discovered
next up and the ring Carbajal he was a
5-foot tall Cuban national and former
mailman turned athlete to get to st.
Louis Carbajal had to raise money by
competing and running events including a
700 mile race across Cuba once he got to
st. Louis he was easy to spot among the
sleeveless shirts and thigh-highs shorts
Carbajal wore a billowing long-sleeve
shirt cut off slacks and work boots he
didn't dress like a sports champion but
damn did he run like one with each and
every step Carbajal charged towards the
finish line even though his legs never
gave out his grumbling stomach peeled to
satisfy his hunger he ate some apples
from a nearby orchard that turned out to
be rotten so he took a little recovery
nap and then proceeded to finish in
fourth place and then there's Thomas
Hicks the gold winner the top dog the
champion the barely standing living
cadaver you see Hicks was so physically
ill that he couldn't cross the finish
line without the help of his trainers
why well back then stimulants were legal
and strychnine a type of rat poison was
thought to have performance-enhancing
properties so during the run his
trainers gave him small doses to gain an
edge but instead of helping him it was
slowly killing him once Hicks was
dragged across the finish line he wasn't
in a cheery mood having lost 8 pounds
during the race he was a hollowed-out
husk of a man the judges shrugged who
gave Hicks the gold ending the nightmare
as the crowd swooned over Hicks
disheveled body somewhere in the stands
James Sullivan was probably sipping on a
glass of fresh water feeling proud of
putting together the worst marathon ever
you
[Music]